bonsoir mes amis dans les sept huit
sociétés avocats notaires huissiers de
justice mais également greffier
représentants des tribunaux de commerce
commissaire priseur mandataire
judiciaire
tous ou presque étaient dans la rue ce
10 décembre pour protester contre la loi
macron qui était présenté ce jour-là en
conseil des ministres un projet de loi
non pas juridique mais économique un
projet censé libérer la croissance et
qui promet de réformer les professions
réglementées alors des juristes dans la
rue c'est assez rare pour le souligner
nous avons voulu comprendre pourquoi
toutes ces professions que se sont
réunis ensemble et ce qu'elles craignent
vraiment est ce que les consommateurs
peuvent gagner ou pas à travers
l'application de cette peau pour en
parler
en plateau ce soir trois représentants
de ces professions maître florence
mercadé choqué bonsoir bonsoir avant
quatre mètres dominique c'est vrai
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
chambre des notaires des yvelines et m
catherine message bonsoir des tenanciers
de justice alors juste avant de débuter
j'aurais juste précis pour cette fois
macro ne concerne pas que vos
professions elle évoque aussi le travail
le dimanche
les transports les permis de compte le
permis de conduire la vie des
entreprises et des salariés dont c'est
une loi assez assez large
ma première question elle concerne ce
qu'on appelle des professions
réglementées parce qu'on a beaucoup
entendu parler du tarn professions
réglementées je me tourne vers vous
mettre à savourer ça veut dire quoi une
profession réglementée
je crois d'abord la dénomination
professions réglementées elle le
comprend beaucoup de professions pour
faire simple la profession réglementée
c'est une c'est un cadre réglementaire
qui est donné un certain nombre de
professions qui ont une mission
particulière cette mission pour les
notaires c'est d'authentifier les apps
et de s'assurer de la sécurité juridique
c'est de s'assurer de l'efficacité des
actes qu'elle reçoit et donc ça justifie
un cadre et ça justifie des contraintes
et des devoirs
les deux joueurs c'est l'obligation
d'être inspectés c'est l'obligation de
gérer les flux financiers de les
sécuriser
c'est l'obligation de s'assurer de l'
équilibre de la convention et je crois
que c'est justifié de les appeler ça une
profession réglementée dans bon sens du
terme
mais vos trois professeurs sont pas
réglementés de la même manière mais si
j'utilise ces
voisine donc la non réglementation
jumelage email et nous nos conditions
d'accès aussi sont réglementées un sens
hawks qui est important aussi c'est que
l'accès est réglementé par des règles
légales
par contre la profession d'avocat pas
non nous ne sommes pas réglementer ce
qui pourrait s'apparenter une
réglementation n'en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure c'est le phénomène de la
postulation mais c'est bon on en parlera
effet si on va commencer par parler de
la fixation des tarifs de nos terres
alors ce qu'on le peut lire en tout cas
dans le projet de loi m'accrocher que
les règles sont anciennes que notamment
les tarifs pour les notaires ont été
définies en 1978 que celles pour les
huissiers en 1996 et que du coup il faut
revoir cette fixation des tarifs alors
sur le fond c'est plutôt de bonnes
choses non pour le consommateur en tout
cas le vieux tarifs ou peut-être
expliquer rapidement pourquoi y un tarif
le tarif il est important parce qu'il
permet à chacun des usagers du droit de
savoir précisément 1 combien il va être
traitée sur le plan financier sur le
plan des honoraires quel que soit
l'endroit où ils se trouvent en france
donc on a beaucoup parlé de tarifs le
tarif il faut savoir que ce sont les
honoraires on parle des frais de notaire
aussi un du tarif des frais de notaire
d'ailleurs une confusion
en réalité le tarif cdn horaires du
notaire les honoraires du notaire c'est
ce que le notaire touche pas
personnellement pour son entreprise
ce avec lequel il paye ses salariés il
paye ses charges
j'ai quelques exemples vous donner
rapidement pour une vente à 200000 euros
par exemple on dit que les frais de
notaire sont de 14 mille trois cents
euros globalement les honoraires perçus
par le notaire ou les notaires sont de
2800 euros et lé 12 milles restant est
double il reste ans et va à l'état
d'ailleurs ça va augmenter le 1er
janvier
parce que dans les yvelines faut savoir
que les frais versés à l'état c'est pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat les frais
versés à l'état vont augmenter de 1400
euros
donc si vous voulez en réalité on a deux
choses on a les frais de notaire qui
comprennent les frais versés à l'état
les impôts la collecte de l'impôt et les
honoraires versés aux notaires et son
entreprise c'est même cas de figure pour
les haïtiens
nous club allemand en grande partie nos
tarifs sont réglementés par un décret
tarifaire une partie reste libre et les
actes qui n'auraient pas qu'ils
n'auraient pas été privé par ce dernier
des grecs vous avez cités on procéderait
par assimilation
donc nous nous référons pour nos actes
de procédure à ce tarif réglementé c'est
une sécurité pour le justiciable et
c'est c'est aussi pour nous la
possibilité de ne pas être dans un
terrain concurrentiel avec un confrère
qui pour un même acte fera un tarif
différent donc le justiciable
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
c'est ce qui va lui être facturé
aujourd'hui effectivement la réforme
envisage une autre un autre système de
facturation sur lequel nous ne sommes
pas opposés qui serait plus forfaitaires
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous avons un tarif
par acte ce qui est très complète aucun
avion pour la vente d'un ce qu'ils
appellent un petit bien immobilier parce
que c'est qu'un petit bien animé par la
banda petit bien immobilier ou un
constat d'huissier
ce serait un tarif moins élevé en tout
cas pas alors le constat des corps et
danses libres et justement le le contre
exemple puisque le constat d'huissier
temps tarif libre
donc il dépend du temps passé du
confrère du secteur géographique
la difficulté du constat aussi un par
contre tout ce qui par exemple un
commandement de payer en vertu d'un
jugement
c'est un tarif unique pour l'ensemble et
justice d'avoir ça veut dire que vous
soyez plutôt favorable à une révision de
ses tarifs
alors la révision tarifs de toute façon
nous avons connu il ya quelques années
à partir du moment où elle nous permet
nous de payer nos nos charges générales
d'avoir une rentabilité qui soit
suffisante au fonctionnement de nos
études avec du personnel qualifié avec
des outils informatiques qui sont très
performants on n'est pas contre une
révision tarifaire à partir du moment où
elle est juste et elle tient compte
on parle d'un coût raisonnable mais il
faut que tous les paramètres soient bien
soit bien prise en compte et du côté du
côté des notaires c'est un petit peu
plus complexe le projet ma croûte est
qu'il est en vie
aujourd'hui parlent d'un corps il parle
de choses il parle d'abord d'un corridor
un corridor pour d'ailleurs dans des
zones qu'on ignorait pas exact qu'on
ignore un peu globalement le corridor ça
veut dire qu'il ya un minima et un
maxima ça veut dire qu'il ya une
négociation qui peut soulager la
négociation des honoraires pour un autre
terre qui est un officier public ça pose
un certain nombre de difficultés
une difficulté tout simple vous achetez
un bien qui fait cent mille euros
je considère moi que cette acquisition
et ses honoraires qui me francs versés
ne me permettent pas de rentabiliser
cette opération j'ai aujourd'hui une
obligation d'instrumenter j'ai une
obligation de recevoir cet acte est ce
que je continuerai à voir cette
obligation d'instrumenter demain si je
peux négocier mes honoraires et que je
ne suis pas d'accord avec la personne
qui veut qu'il veut négocier avec moi
ces jeunes rêvent donc ça pose de
nombreux problèmes
aujourd'hui le tarif des notaires tel
qu'il est envisagé permet d'avoir cette
compensation entre des actes qu'ils sont
très bien payés et des acquis sont très
mal payés
si on veut changer on peut leur est visé
par ce qui est effectivement aujourd'hui
ce tarif est relativement illisible il
faut le rendre beaucoup plus lisible
beaucoup plus simple mais il faut
permettre et je rejoins ce que disait
lui cette justice il faut permettre ce
tarif de pouvoir nous permettre
d'exercer notre mission de service
public dans des conditions normales
c'est à dire illisible c'est compliqué
si vous voulez il ya des tranches iliad
était il ya des taux différents en
fonction du type d'acte en fonction du
c'est trop compliqué alors je précise
d'ailleurs là-dessus que on a dit que le
tarif n'avait pas été révisé ce qui est
faux le tarif a été révisé et encore pas
longtemps notamment les règles de
fixation qui ont été définies en 79 des
règles de fixation est il prévu en 78
mais en réalité il a évoqué la du temps
quand même 70 a fait du temps absolument
mais il a évolué depuis et il a évolué à
tel point que d'ailleurs on a même
diminué un certain nombre de tarifs
notamment je parle sur les prêts
hypothécaires d'habitation notamment
on évoque une autre
d'autres questions qui est dans la loi
un contre projet doit c'est la liberté
d'installation
aujourd'hui la situation d'exercice de
certaines professions juridiques comme
le notaire les 8,6 n'est possible que
dans le cadre régime de numerus clausus
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
donc comment pas toutefois pas tout à
fait pas tout à fait parce que le
numerus clausus est apte à fait exact
demain un jeune qui est diplômé notaire
qui a sa formation juridique veut
s'installer notaire qui peut
parfaitement s'associer oui les
précédentes études mais existant en
revanche c'est vrai que créer une étude
de rien faire poser sa plaque comme le
feraient par exemple un avocat ça n'est
pas possible sous réserve de l'accord de
la chancellerie d'accord il ya quand
même ces deux hommes très réglementé
donc il est contraint et il doit
s'associer ou alors il doit acheter ça
veut dire que donc ça coûte cher de
s'installer pour être notaire ou pour
être initié cette même semaine principe
donc la liberté d'installation elle
semble logique
quelques pas alors la liberté un set
d'abord c'est la voie la rue grand
souffle alors ce qui fait peur c'est
d'abord pour la jeunesse c'est pour ces
jeunes qui vont s'installer à qui on
proposerait une installation sur un
territoire qui est déjà desservie par
d'autres vicié qui seraient
éventuellement obligée d'indemniser
c'est huissier qui pendant un certain
nombre d'années qu'on peut bien évaluer
cinq ans n'aurait chine aurait un
chiffre d'affaires qui ne leur
permettrait pas de payer leurs charges
alors qu'ils auraient dû investir dans
du personnel du matériel informatique et
qui serait en fait qui serait huissier
au rabais donc les jeunes moi je suis
enseignante à l'école nationale de
procédure qui forme le futur huissier
les jeunes préfèrent une semaine fin me
parle d'une sécurité à s'associer avec
un us expérimentée parce que les études
sont longues mais la vie professionnelle
on se bonifie en augmente notre
expérience et donc notre qualité
professionnelle tout au long de notre
carrière donc ces jeunes isolés avec un
chiffre d'affaires et des charges qui ne
leur permettrait pas de vivre dignement
ce ne sera certainement pas un cadeau
quant aux confrères qui ont acheté leurs
études parce que on nous a contraints à
acheter l'étude 1
on n'a pas voulu capitaliser on nous a
dit ça je présume que ça coûte assez
cher de ce type d'étude donc c'est pas
la portée de leurs étudiants diplômés
faut savoir que ce n'est pas un prix
libre
c'est un prix qui est vérifiée bien
qu'il soit déterminé de gré à gré c'est
un briquet vérifié par la chancellerie
et qui réduit à la demande de la
chancellerie qui ne laisse pas passer
les dossiers
si les dossiers dépassent des limites
quand t'es fixé par la chancellerie
il faut savoir aussi qu aujourd'hui les
prêts des banques privées et de la
chambre nationale qui finance une grande
partie de l'installation ne nécessite
pas d'apport personnel
donc on n'est pas obligé d'emprunter à
100% quand on est intéressant pour c'est
la même chose pour un c'est pareil pour
les thermes et joël revenir deux minutes
sur la liberté d'installation parce que
c'est assez effectivement vrai sujet
cette liberté d'installation il faut
comprendre pourquoi on m'avait posé la
question de l'heure de la profession
réglementée
vu les missions qui nous sont confiées
qui sont quand même particulièrement
importante puisque en réalité le notaire
mais un saut sur ces contrats il est une
délégation de service public qui
représente l'état
ça ne permet pas à n'importe qui de
pouvoir mettre sa plaque où il veut
quand il veut c'est incompatible sinon
il ya une mission de service public
donc à partir de là il faut qu'on puisse
maîtriser un peu de savoir qui va
rentrer ce qu'il à la formation skil a
la compétence est ce qu'il a le yacht et
la probité l'honorabilité et c'est ça
certaines installations ça n'empêche pas
d'avoir un contrôle
c'est plus une liberté d'installation si
vous pouviez plus que mettre votre
plaque à tout moment il n'y a plus aucun
contrôle de nulle part
c'est plus une véritable si liberté
d'installation complète alors le
deuxième point et qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que la profession
notariale est garante dans son ensemble
et solidaires dans son ensemble cirque
le jour et c'est important de le
comprendre le jour où un notaire fait
une erreur grave
eh bien c'est la profession ensemble qui
est responsable et cette garantie
elle est comprise en tarif d'accord mais
en même temps puis-je accepté d'être
solidaire d'un hôtel qui s'installent
n'importe où n'importe quand et que je
n'ai pas choisie forcément non la
garantie collectif ne est incompatible
avec cette liberté d'installation donc
liberté favoriser l'accès aux jeunes
c'est évident qu'il faut le favoriser et
on est tout à fait demandeur moi même je
fais l'enseignement et je peux vous
garantir que l'autre jour à la
manifestation
il y avait des étudiants qui étaient là
aussi parce qu'ils sont partisans tu le
cep d'une d'une évolution n'est pas
d'une liberté d'installation complète
donc évidemment il faut favoriser cette
installation des jeunes mais pas
n'importe comment et n'importe quoi
c'est quand même un problème à résoudre
c'est le vieillissement de vos
populations
je crois que la moyenne d'âge pour un
notaire ses 49 ans et ses 49 ans aussi
pour un huissier donc segment des
moyennes qui sont assez élevé je crois
qu'à 10% de moins en moins par un
jeunisme chez les femmes après il ya eu
toute une génération d'anciennes
huissier d'ailleurs avec une formation
universitaire très différentes qui a
laissé sa place à une nouvelle
génération et nous assurons nos taux de
renouvellement
parce que nous avons notre propre centre
de formation et au cas pas de
problématique du vieillissement de vos
populations je croque la vie boom qui
est vraiment celle sur le port des
statistiques on est en plein dedans
aujourd'hui nous on sait le notariat
s'est engagée par rapport à cette
problématique de liberté d'installation
et d'accès des jeunes elle s'y est
engagé vis-à-vis de monsieur macron à
dire on est prêt à accueillir 300 jeunes
nouveaux notaire par an voilà je crois
que la réponse à l'élan y aller il est
évident qu'il faut axer il faut
permettre l'accès aux jeunes c'est comme
ça que la profession pourra se maintenir
pour à se dynamiser pour à innover
encore et davantage
petite annotation complémentaires sur le
sur le maillage territorial certes la
liberté d'installation
elle doit aussi veiller au marais un bon
maillage territorial dans les dernières
années dans la dernière décennie les
études rurales beaucoup d'études rurales
ont disparu beaucoup d'études semi rural
se sont regroupés parce que nos donneurs
d'ordre sont devenus des entités qui
elle-même se sont rachetés donc
aujourd'hui
l'huissier isolé c'est un huissier en
danger et sa musique qui n'assure plus
le service que son donneur d'ordres
sollicite donc la liberté d'installation
récupérer le maillage territorial
ça ne doit pas aller contre la qualité
du service ni ni sur des études qui
seront déficitaires parce que pourquoi
les petites études ont disparu parce
qu'elle n'était plus rentable
je rappelle 18% étude d'huissiers au
moins depuis 1980 il y aura les mêmes
chiffres au niveau national pour les
notaires il ya 600 études notariales en
moins en 25 ans mais vous quatre ans à
bord et vous me dites non c'est pas vrai
témoin je serai pas dans les îles jeune
je ne lis je peux vous des chiffres des
yvelines il n'y a plus il ya plus de 20
pour plus de 20% d'études et plus de 25%
de nos terres depuis dix ans donc les
chiffres nationaux
je pense qu'ils sont liés au fait qu' il
ya vraisemblablement jeudi saint sous
réserve vraisemblable d'aia mais les
revêtements et eu des regroupements
d'études cirque en fait il y avait des
études avec des bureaux secondaires et
qui à l'époque n'était pas des bureaux
secondaires qui constituent des études
et qui en se regroupant avec une autre
étude mais en maintenant la présence sur
le territoire
il ya peut-être effectivement une
diminution mais je suis un peu sceptique
sur les chiffres qui sont sortis en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
sur les sources au ministère de
l'économie
bon enfin su à temps les choses du
ministère l'économie permettez-moi de le
dire que le rapport un lit gf
contenaient un certain nombre d'erreurs
aussi et de contrevérités personne n'est
parfait
on va maintenant s'intéresser aux
avocats on a bien compris que noté
russie sont les professions jumelles on
va s'intéresser à la problématique des
avocats l'ont déjà il ya une chose que
vous avez obtenus c'était le statut
d'avocat en entreprise qui qui va être
un temps été évoqué dans la loi et
finalement ça sera pas le cas non c'est
plutôt du premier bateau oui c'est une
première satisfaction sachant que ce
statut d'avocat en entreprise n'a jamais
été demandée par la profession et par
qui que ce soit au niveau des barreaux
donc on était un peu étonné de l'avoir
vu apparaître un certain moment il a été
retiré du projet de loi et on a et on a
découvert donc dernièrement qu'il avait
été réinsérés dans le projet de loi et
finalement il vient d'être retirée donc
il n'est plus dans le projet de loi
c'était surtout un statut qui était
plutôt demandé par les entreprises que
par les avocats
en fait ça permettait quoi sauvegarde
être non non non ça ça existe déjà les
avocats salariés existe puisque dans un
cabinet d'avocats on peut avoir le
statut libéral ou le statut de salarié
mais là ça permettait à une entreprise
d'avoir des juristes qui au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années deviennent
avocats prête serment deviennent avocats
d'entreprise mais non pas perdre non pas
de clientèle personnelle ne peuvent pas
pu ne pouvait pas plaider pour l'entrée
pour son employeur puisqu'il était
salarié ne peut pas plaider pour son
employeur sauf devant le prix d'aumale
tribunal de commerce il en avait le
pouvoir est en fait ça sécurisé au
niveau des affaires la confidentialité
de ce qu'ils étaient échangées dans
l'entreprise
en fait l'objectif d en trouver c'était
avoir de la confidentialité des échanges
mais ça n'empêchait pas que cet avocat
ne pouvait pas plaider ne pouvait pas
représenter son employeur est resté
finalement au fond un juriste avec une
confidentialité
ça c'est fini maintenant ça existe ça
c'est vous c'est la postulation en l2
c'est un peu un peu à la musculation et
l'ouverture de l'accès au capital de la
postulation c'est en voisine chaque
avocat est libre de plaider sur
l'ensemble du territoire
toutefois un avocat ne peut postuler que
devant le tribunal de grande instance du
barreau dont il dépend si un client fait
appel à un avocat
pour cet avocat ne dépend pas du tgi
obligé de faire appel à un autre avocat
local et ça fait double ferait donc sa
part tout en bleu frais parce qu'en
local local les moins chers moi j'aime
pas c'est à dire que lui il ne
représentera et fera quelques failli il
signifiera les adopte sa série mieux
cher aux clients saas et ses clacs alors
deux amants temps peut pas dire coûtera
ça coûte ça coûte plus cher cher
puisqu'ils sont mais ça c'est indéniable
à mailly a des avantages alors vous
expliquer le projet doit ne remet pas en
cause le monopole de la postulation des
avocats mais du coup il est temps il
élargit le périmètre du tgi à la cour
d'appel absolument comprendre le thème
est récurrent
on se dit c'est plutôt pas mal alors non
fin août notre point de vue c'est pas
plutôt pas mal moi c'était ma fille
obama pour les avocats ont aussi je
pense que ça peut avoir alors j'en sais
rien c'est au-delà pendant ce temps on
fait de la projection
mais je pense que ça peut avoir des
effets des effets contre-productifs et
surtout contre-productif pour les
justiciables en premier lieu
je tiens à attirer l'attention sur 2.1
nous on a toujours été très choqué de ce
que c'est une réforme de notre
profession au fond parce que ça va avoir
des impacts sur la réforme de notre
profession et j'en ai très choquée que
ce soit porté par bercy ce qui est un
message fort n'est pas posée à ce qui se
passait mais voilà je vais leur demander
ce qui veut dire que c'est une loi
clairement qui affiche sa couleur qui
est une loi économique one qui lui le
but est de réduire les coûts mais en
même temps c'est un mouvement sa réforme
des professions où on est auxiliaire de
justice
nous on n'est peut-être pas réglementé
mais on est auxiliaire de justice et on
dépend du ministère de la justice donc
déjà nous ça nous a fait un peu bondir
mais ce qui donne la couleur quand même
de la portée de cette loi ou en fait ce
cas c'est le droit c'est de l'affichage
c'est le droit est un produit de
consommation alors qu'à mon sens il ya
un débat ça c'est vrai que ça c'est vous
qui le dites moi c'est moi qui dis mais
c'est un peu comme ça qu'on le ressent
au trésor la population donc sur la
postulation l'idée c'est que cette loi
aussi le conseil d'état a retoqué le
gouvernement là dessus n'a pas fait du
tout 2
d'étude d'impact de la loi sur les
professions ce soit les notaires les
huissiers ou les avocats et l'étude
d'impact si on l'avait fait un tant soit
peu sur cette population élargie et j'y
viens au niveau de la cour d'appel
il faut quand même savoir que nos
barreaux sont rattachés à des tribunaux
de grande instance
c'est pour ça qu'on a ce monopole de
représentation très bien de grande
instance
si on est en train de dire que la
postulation va partir de manière élargie
sur une cour d'appel dont plusieurs
tribunaux de grande instance dépendent
cela veut dire que les cabinets qui
seront toujours dans les tribunaux de
grande instance qui n'auront plus du
coup ces affaires là qui vont partir au
niveau des cours d'appel puisque la
postulation maintenant tout le monde
pourra postuler sur tous les tribunaux
de grande instance
je pense que là derrière ça va être la
disparition de petits cabinets qu'ils
pourront plus faire face parce que ce
qui va se passer nécessairement avec
l'ouverture du capital puisque c'est le
deuxième point
l'ouverture de notre capital de cabinet
à la terre entière sauf les banques et
les assurances ça veut dire qu'il y aura
des regroupements de cabinet autour des
cours d'appel avec des cabinets
important peut-être avec des cabinets il
y aura des notaires des experts
comptables des avocats mais avec des
cabinets qui s'adresseront à une
certaine catégorie de la population et
qui laisseront sur le bord de la route
toute une autre catégorie de population
qui avait justement des contacts avec
des cabinets dans des villes mais dans
des petites villes où il y avait des tg
qui vont forcément il ya 161 tgi en
france et on se retrouve à 36 cour
d'appel donc on voit que y avoir des tas
de villes ou des petits cabinets
d'avocats qui vivaient aussi avec la
postulation qui était un lien un
maillage territorial un lien avec les
juges
bah ils n'auront plus d'affaires et ses
cabinets vont disparaître et comme la
nature absolument horreur du vide vous
allez avoir des associations locales qui
vont prétendre faire du droit et je
doute que ça remonte le droit et je
craigne que ça paupérise le droit que y
aura moins d'accès au droit ça va poser
des problèmes sur l'aide
juridictionnelle qui dépend toujours du
tribunal de grande instance
donc comment on fait pour l'aide
juridictionnelle comment on fait pour
les permanences comment on fait pour les
commissions d'office
je pense que les justiciables alors j'en
sais rien si ça va se passer comme ça ou
pas mais c'est possible comme on a pas
d'étude d'impact on peut pas le savoir
mais c'est possible ça se passe de cette
manière là et que du coup les
justiciables n'est plus le cabinet
d'avocats où ils pouvaient aller taper à
la porte le samedi matin en rentrant du
marché et ça ça va disparaître et on va
se retrouver des gros cabinet d'avocats
pour certes pour certains
un client potentiel et certains
justiciables qui ont les moyens d'aller
dans ces cabinets d'avocats et les
petits vont disparaître et ça je pense
que c'est pas dans l'intérêt du
justiciable
le dans la postulation élargi nation
dépend ce que pour des gens qui sont
effectivement milieu rural dans des
petites villes
ils iront pas dans des très gros cabinet
d'avocats notaires etc forcément tu as
payé de la porte près des cours d'appel
autre chose mais c'est peut-être que ça
se passera pas comme ça je le souhaite
autre chose qui fait bondir aussi votre
profession c'est l'ouverture de l'accès
au capital
oui alors baffe notre problématique du
coup ça va enrichir les cabinets
d'avocats enfin ça va enrichir certains
cabinets d'avocats je vois pas les
petits cabinets d'avocats avoir
d'ouverture sauf peut-être à la famille
s'ils ont des problèmes de trésorerie ou
ils n'arrivent pas emprunter une banque
mais le gros restée sur l'indépendance
de notre profession dire que nous notre
indépendance que l'on a vis à vis de nos
clients
c'est un moment donné de leur dire dans
le cadre de notre conseil non vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça non je vous le
déconseille map à 6,6 ce client la
détient les trois quarts enfin peut-être
pas encore mais la moitié de notre
capitale comment on leur dit non ça vous
ne pouvez pas le faire et je vous
déconseille de le faire ils ne diront
pas le savoir vous faites
or l'indépendance est une valeur sacrée
de notre profession voilà pourquoi on
est aussi opposée à cette ouverture la
même problématique il on a beaucoup
réduit par l'avancée des projets
l'intégration de capitaux privés dans
nos études
notre indépendance financière c'est la
garantie de notre déontologie
si on détient pas notre capitale si
notre capitaine n'appartient pas des
gens qui ont les mêmes règles
déontologiques que nous ces attaques
nous a effectivement qu'il faut
comprendre que j'aurais juste rebondir
sur la copie non parce qu'on va conclure
excusez moi sur la compétence
territoriale nous aujourd'hui
le projet de loi prévoit une compétence
au niveau de la cour d'appel
aujourd'hui nous sommes au 1er janvier
nous serons sur une compétence eau et
aux ressorts départementale mois sur les
yvelines j'ai un million quatre cent
mille personnes 1 million 400 mille
débiteur ou créanciers potentiels
j'ai 2284 kilomètres carrés
et il n'y a pas une commune où je ne
vais pas ce sera impossible au niveau de
la cour d'appel je serai obligé de me
groupé avec des études et on va tomber
sur des méga groupement avec pour le
justiciable de proximité une disparition
pour les maillages elle comprend que
l'une des problématiques et une des
peurs c'est effectivement ces
regroupements obligatoire de fait avec
le le maillage la loi a été présenté le
10 décembre en conseil des ministres
elle sera débattue le 22 janvier à
l'assemblée nationale dernière question
est ce que vous allez encore vous
mobiliser d'ici là c'est prévu je crois
que tout les toutes les professions
libérales ont prévu d'être de manifester
le 22 janvier on va se mobiliser
largement savez il ya une chose
importante c'est qu'on a du mal à
comprendre fondamentalement l'esprit de
cette loi puisque je le dis clairement
en tête les notaires on à 0,8 pour mille
le contentieux sur deux contrats on a
une organisation une modernisation
complète honda sûr et sécurisé les flux
financiers
donc on n'arrive pas à comprendre ce
qu'on comprend par contre c'est que
l'effet de cette loi aura des effets
catastrophiques sur l'emploi on à 1400
salariés aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
dans les yvelines val d'oise et sur les
jeunes auteurs qui sont endettés pour
acheter leurs études et ça c'est
embêtant
donc on va se mobiliser donc
mobilisation encore des professions
dites réglementé des inventaires aussi
et puis d autres des médecins aussi
puisqu'à dépression libéral aussi sont
les professions libérales tout court
seront donc dans la rue à nouveau le 22
janvier parce que la loi sera débattu à
ce moment-là à l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup à vous trois pour votre
éclairage sera donné sur le plateau 17,8
société bonne soirée